لم تكن المؤامره الانقلابيه التي كشفت
عنها المانيا حدثا عابرا فلا تزال خيوطها
تتكشف يوما بعديهم تحقيق لرويترز كشف عن
علاقات تربط شخصيه رئيسيه تقود حركا في
المانيا بالدوله الروسيه او باقصى اليمين
التحقيقات ابرزت ان هذه الشخصيات تدفع
بموقف مؤيد لموسكو داخل المانيا منذ بدء
الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا الامر يتعلق
بظبط سابق في سلاح الجو الروسي وكان يطلق
عليه في الاصل روستس لارتسيوك وغير اسمه
الى ماكس لندن استقر في المانيا قبل عقد
من الزمن والثاني يدعى
ويتعهد بالولاء الاسلاميين الشرقيين الذين
يدعمون حمله موسكو العسكريه في اوكرانيا
في حين يتخذ اخرون بعض الاسماء المستعاره
ولديهم علاقات غير معلنه مع روسيا
والكيانات الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبه
الدوليه او بمنظمه اليمين المتطرف
وينشر بعض النشاط الموالينا لروسيا رسائل
الكريم لاين على الانترنت للجمهور الناطق
بالالمانيه تحليل رويترز وجد لقنوات
تليغرام باللغه الالمانيه مالا يقل عن 27
قناه تعيد باستمرار مشاركه الرسائل
المؤيده للكرملين الى جمهور مشترك يبلغ
نحو مليون و500,000 شخص بلال الوجداني
العربيه